mm-hmm I might throws like what my name
is Peter Byrne we're gonna play Barbie
adventure let's cook new game another
one the castle Barbie break Leah heads
for the castle Oh Barbie you're so brave
how can I be like you
[Music]
Wow you're you gotta be really brave to
and there this mother I'll let's see how
we do this comfortable okay go over the
bridge
oh no Barbie know Barbie why why it was
no Barbie Barbie Barbie look at me
Barbie Barbie
there you go Barbie there you go oh the
channels good Barbie go go Barbie go go
go go Barbie go go go head over the toe
okay we got it we got it we're into the
first we enter the cattle alright
alright let's go
this is [ __ ] creepy I think we need
this
bill though right here cuz Barbie is
horny horny bastard okay Barbie monster
go downstairs yes go Barbie go Bobby go
Marvin go Barbie look at me yes okay go
Bobby go Bobby go Bobby go go Bobby go
down the stairs no no the gate no thank
you I have the you guys you think you're
probably think I'm really stupid but
seriously the controls are so so oh so
amazing I mean [ __ ] like I'm
seriously trying my best here I'm not
trying to be a [ __ ] for you guys I
swear I don't know why I would go Barbie
go bar we go you have to go with what
the gate closes go Barbie look at me go
Barbie go Barbie go go Barbie go but God
burn carbon really go go don't why would
you go into the frickin wall yes okay I
got it I got it Wow Wow really
who made this room in the [ __ ] castle
well yeah I'm gonna make a castle full
of clouds and chid alright
and I got a [ __ ] phone call hold on
hey Felix
Hey don't mean to put women on their
differing up on Bella how did ah hi okay
let's continue with Barbie seriously
though Oh going through the tree yes yes
yes that was the trickiest room ever
collect the stars like stars like this
Barbie [ __ ] series here Barbie always
messes around while I'm trying to do
this serious Barbie look at me I'm
Barbie and while I do all the hard work
give me a Barbie look at me we're just
as married in my can where's my king I
wanna go alone with my dildo I mean my
ice nope no kid that finds this like
some poor eight-year-old girl expects to
see Barbie and she won't be nah nah she
should be happy
she should be [ __ ] happy I'm doing
this all right we got one done yes this
is your secret code do you honestly
expect me to remember this be shoe
necklace rose B shoe necklace rules is
there some hidden message you should be
a shoe and then you should combine a
necklace to a rolls
that makes [ __ ] sense Barbie
magically becomes smaller yeah that also
makes my [ __ ] sense
Barbie you're small no you're not you're
exactly the same size and you're in a
drink you ended up in no Barbie focus
Barbie focus by me focus baby focus
Barbie focus Barbie focus baby focus
Barbie I finally got the controls done I
think focus Barbie focus Barbie yes okay
uh-oh I need some water the black Barbie
I need to water the plant
no Barbie no good Barbie good Barbie I
wonder how many times I would say Barbie
in this walkthrough go Barbie go go yes
you need to water the flowers okay I'm
gonna water you might know oh I get it I
get it I get it
I got it I got it I got it I need water
this plant over here go Barbie water the
plant do it somehow no I'm [ __ ] stuck
in a kid's game [ __ ] great water the
plant where did I even come from it
makes no sense
come on Barbie just I mean come on just
collaborate with me it's not it's not
about you it's not about me it's about
house and me clicking every [ __ ] key
I have on my keyboard Barbie Barbie
shape the [ __ ] up
wait I need to check the controls hold
on
how to play Barbie I need to read the
[ __ ] instruct instructions to do this
okay how to play there are I don't give
a [ __ ] is how you walk and that's all
they give you oh great
just king amazing Barbie Barbie Barbie
look at me Barbie I know you're upset
but don't go away just wanna kiss every
flower oh holy [ __ ] I just hump it
apparently yeah that makes sense okay I
got it I got it I was just pretending to
be stuck in a kids game just to although
there's actually monsters now holy [ __ ]
Go Go Barbie go No
oh it's coming for me okay we can do
this time you need to shape up like
seriously how often do you exercise
sorry Barbie I didn't [ __ ] come on okay
go Barbie go I'm going I'm going I'm
going I'm going
holy [ __ ] I'm alive
I'm stock Barbie why-why-why Barbie why
why this is look at me Barbie
it's look at me while I'm talking to you
Barbie [ __ ] you Barbie
ok let's see if I remember the [ __ ]
code there was a bee
yeah and a shoe and then I actually
[ __ ] remember
holy [ __ ] magically I have to do this
yeah ok it's cool it's cool
are you kidding me go go huh I'm
standing on it sorry this is ridiculous
go Barbie go Barbie go Barbie go Barbie
Barbie girls where Bobby goes there are
holes I mean what I meant holds like
slangs not know where we go not you know
you know go Bobby go Bobby go Bobby go
Bobby go Barbie yes yes go go go go go
Barbie hey yo go go go go
Barbie hey yo I'm slick I'm a [ __ ] I
must like I must let I almost like I'm a
say
Barbossa slit mm-hmm but seriously going
Barbie Barbie open the door
okay here's the tricky part and don't
let the mice killer okay I seriously
think he has some sort of speaking Asian
because I can't I understand it this is
really tricky go Barbie go now
see this [ __ ] thing again be shoe
necklace thing she becomes smaller okay
let's get it
bar baby okay okay go Barbie Barbie
Barbie Barbie Barbie Barbie Barbie
Barbie Barbie okay we got it
okay this [ __ ] thing for the third
time Barbie Suzy I hate this [ __ ] I hate
her so [ __ ] much this seriously
stressful come on
if the controls weren't so bad this
would have been a piece of cake
seriously she keeps wanting to spend I
don't know why okay okay I'm super
serious now Barbie
don't [ __ ] this up for me no don't I
can't move
I'm stuck again why be shoe [ __ ]
necklaces I'm gonna do this I swear to
my Barbie Barbie Barbie why do you do
this to me why I had thought nothing
against you I've really done nothing
okay for time why not we sent three
times a charm
four times it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] come on
Barbie Barbie Barbie Barbie Barbie
Barbie Barbie Barbie might be Barbie yes
yes yes yes yes yes
Barbie yes yes yes Barbie yes it sounds
perverted yes yes [ __ ] it I'm gonna do
it anyway yes yes yes Barbie yeah sorry
I know what got into me there she was
just too good to me for a second okay
there we go okay I'm [ __ ] serious now
Barbie don't did I tell you the [ __ ]
move
okay okay this is serious business stop
spinning okay go go
oh okay mother oh [ __ ] I respond at
least okay okay I don't want to go go go
go go
[Music]
my god